sie haben nach kofi annan benannt
jetzt gerade becker mit beginnt live
wieder ins kreisen sicherlich ein holz
der touristen wann dürfen den deutschen
wieder in den usa für urlaubs zwecke
oder für geschäftszwecke reisen arbeiten
gerade daran ich arbeite sehr hart und
ich habe auch mit dem präsidenten zu
diesem thema gesprochen
indem wir die grenzen wieder öffnen und
wieder reguläre reisemöglichkeiten zu
lassen nun die deutsche haben sehr gute
arbeit geleistet es gibt bereits pflege
zwischen münchen und umland sind einige
amerikanische städte wir sollten das
langsam angehen lassen wir sollten erst
einmal das terrain sondieren alles tun
was wir können und so immer eine art
testlauf zu haben
münchen mit amerikanischen destinationen
sagt mir zuerst verbinden und zwar so
schnell wie möglich ich habe gespräche
mit der lufthansa geführt erich den
posten auftrag und auch mit anderen
fluggesellschaften die ebenfalls
interessiert sind ich glaube dass dies
allmählich beginnt es gibt seitens der
usa den wunsch dies zu machen die
grenzen zu öffnen und ich glaube es ist
dass deutschland wirklich das erste land
ist weil ich so gute arbeit geleistet
hat